x
enfants handicapés par exemple.
Voici un dossier de Julie
- Depuis plus de 25 ans,
les gestionnaires de garderie
chacun y va de ses critères.
Une minorité de dirigeants de
services de garde sélectionnent,
par exemple, les enfants selon
Pour y mettre fin,
le gouvernement Legault
imposera, dès 2024 à toutes
les garderies subventionnées,
doivent passer en premier.
Selon ce qu'a appri
Radio-Canada, Québec propose
que les tout-petits ayant
des défis particuliers ou issus
de milieux socioéconomiques
précaires aient la priorité.
La précarité économiqueserait du
familial; la précarité socialels
parents, leur jeune âge,
la monoparentalité,imimimimimimé
autochtone notamment.
Autrement dit, un enfant
issu de l'immigration avec des
parent
aurait beaucoup de points
et passerait avant un enfant
Les gestionnaires de garderie
saluent les efforts
pour améliorer l'accès
aux enfaisisisisisisisisisisisie
la centralisation prévue
va trop loin.
MARIE-ÈVE DOLBEC, DG, CPE Les
p'
- Oui, le ménage était essentiel
et je pense que notre réseau
des CPE est... ils sont tous
d'accord, tous mes collègues,
qu'il était temps de faire
un ménage. Est-ce que...
J'ai un collègue qui a utilisé
l'image, par exemple, du bazooka
peut-être un petit peu trop
intense, le ménage qu'il
en train de nous proposer.
- Lacontenant présentement,
ça fonctionne pas.
- Le président de l'Association
des garderies prouououououououot
de revoir son plan de match.
SAMIR ALAHMAD, Association
des garderies privées du Québec
- Malheuieieieieieieieieieieieir
le gouvernement, nos familles
de la classe moyenne,
elles passent en dernier.
No
inacceptable.
- Les gestionnaires mettent
en garde Québec contre l'idée
d'imposer des critères mur
à prendre en premier.
Ils s'inquiètent aussi
de la disparition de certains
critères comme la proximité,
habitent le quartier.
À Québec, les par
d'opposition n'ont pas
tardé à réagir.
du PQ en matière de famille
- On peut pas erererererer
à partir de Québec et avoir
justement une compréhension
MARC TANGUAY, chef intérimaire,
Parti liuéuéuéuéuéuébec
- La fameuse liste,
là, des 51 000 noms,
la récupérer et bien la gérer.
MANON MASSororororororte-parole,
Québec solidaire
- Si la CAQ avait fait
son treseseseseseseseseseseseset
répondu à ce qu'elle nous
dilllllllllllle voulait que
chaque enfant ait une place,
on serait pas rendu là.
de la Famille se dit confiante
de fais s s s s s changements.
SUZANNE ROY, ministre
de la Famille, Québec
- ququququququququququququququqe
d'admission pour qu'autantrerers
de garde connaissent bien
les règles du jeu. Je penseçaça.
- Après les gestionnaires,
ces derniers mois, ce sera au
tour des parents, dès la semaine
prochaine, de dire au ministère
de cette réforme majeure
prévue dès 20
Ici Julie Marceau,
Radio-Canada, Montréa